watch
so okay i think we are ready to get
started thank you to everyone who is
joining us today and thank you of course
kevin for being here we are live
streaming today's show across a number
of different platforms so wherever you
are joining us from we are so happy to
have you here we've been hosting these
quarterly pitch competitions i think for
a few years now and it's been really
incredible to see how much it's grown i
think kevin you probably remember when
we first started it's probably a couple
hundred viewers now we typically get
upwards of 50 000 people from tuning in
from around the world i can already see
in the chat people introducing
themselves from all over uh so we are
just so happy to have everyone here
and then a couple notes before we begin
so kevin is going to be the one asking
all the questions to the five companies
that are presenting today but of course
we welcome everyone who's watching share
your opinions about the pitches ask your
questions to the founders directly you
never know maybe kevin will see it and
he'll ask that question
and of course if you are wondering how
can you pitch your business to mr
wonderful at the next start in jupiter
show just go to start engine dot com
sharp
uh and for any first time viewers i am
johanna cronin i'm the chief marketing
officer here at star dungeon we are the
leading equity crowdfunding site in the
u.s we have over half a billion dollars
that have been invested into startups
and alternative assets through our site
and of course we have our judge for the
day start engine strategic advisor and
investor kevin o'leary
great to be here jonah just a few words
before we start i always like to say
this before the pitches
same as shark tank same as any pitch
anywhere even an elevator three
attributes that are really important for
people to realize when you're pitching
any investor number one articulate the
opportunity in 90 seconds or less if you
can't explain the deal in a minute and a
half you're lost number two explain why
you have the ability to execute because
great ideas are a dime a dozen but what
is it about you that can take this great
idea and execute on it and lastly and
most importantly know your numbers how
big is the market how fast is it growing
how many competitors what are the gross
margins what the break-even analysis if
you don't know the answers to those
questions when i ask them
i will put you in hell in perpetuity i
guarantee you that thank you
wow amazing concise and brutal but you
know that's what that's what uh finding
an investor is like
okay so we have thousands of investors
who are watching today kevin and i know
a lot of them have been feeling anxious
about the current market what it means
for their business what advice do you
have for founders on how to weather
market volatility
understand that the market's changed in
terms of investors perception and how
they want to risk their capital what
matters now is the path to profitability
and cash flow all of a sudden that
didn't matter for seven years it matters
now
investors want to know how long is their
money tied up before they ever see any
liquidity but more importantly when will
you be profitable i have an old saying
if you can't make money after three
years on a new mandate take it behind
the barn and shoot it so you have to
think about that three years is a long
time you have to have a plan to
profitability a plan for cash flow cash
is king that is a big deal now all
around the world
yeah we have our own uh ceo howard marks
i know you guys had an event yesterday
and you're talking about cash is king
this is really the thing that we're
seeing across the board um and we have a
lot of companies who are wondering is
now the time to raise money should i be
considering doing my next round of
funding right now and if so where would
i even go
yes now is the time the best ideas are
born in stress periods no question about
it and also this is going to be i
believe because i've been involved in
equity crowdfunding now for years but i
i really love this platform it's now
going to shine like no other time
because it offers such a great
opportunity even in times of complete
stress and volatility it allows you to
basically issue shares that very similar
to your own if not identical so you
don't have some preference above you
there's no special terms you're not
forced to the terms of some other entity
like a hedge fund or private equity firm
or venture fund and there's no time in
other words your shareholders may be
your customers they may not have a five
or three year horizon so many great
attributes with equity crowdfunding to
look at and because you're doing it in
relatively small incremental amounts you
can get thousands of shareholders that
can make that decision day in day out
week in week out month in month out and
constantly be tapping this amazing
platform as joanna said this is the
leading platform in america why because
it has all the investors here that's why
so when you put your deal up there
people have a chance to see it make sure
that you have a very compelling video
because it's visual and you're
communicating use social media to drive
business and get out there and sell
that's what it's all about
yeah i couldn't agree more and we've
actually seen a huge uptick in
applications we saw this a little bit
actually in 2020 in the same sort of
high anxiety state where people were
wondering what was next i think this is
going to become a massive moment for
equity crowdfunding so many companies
are seeing this and they're realizing
this is actually the time to raise money
from the crowd
um and then i just wanna you know i know
we have a lot of new faces here so for
anyone who is new and doesn't know what
start engine is we are as kevin said the
largest equity crowdfunding site in the
u.s we've raised half a billion dollars
for companies and we really aim to
enable public access to private
investments that means you can invest in
everything from startups to high-growth
private companies to collectibles like
art watches wine and it's all on the
same site uh and this isn't you know i
think a lot of people wonder is this
just so for super wealthy individuals
large-scale investments it really isn't
we have a community of over 800 000
people investing as little as a hundred
dollars into each of these deals
uh without further ado let's kick it off
so
as i mentioned we have thousands of
applicants but we only selected five
companies to pitch today we're going to
have five companies pitching two minutes
per pitch three minutes from questions
for kevin and afterwards kevin will be
choosing the first place winner who will
receive 25 thousand dollars in cash a
one-on-one with start engine ceo and
co-founder of activision games howard
marks amazing prizes from our partners
plug and play deal brex forecaster and
benzinga and the second place pride is
going to go to the crowd favorite so we
are obviously a big believer in the
crowd you will all have the chance to
actually choose the second place winner
that company is going to win five
thousand dollars okay so first up we
have hollow june please unmute your mic
and turn on your camera
june bet is the founder and ceo of hello
and on-demand language learning platform
for speaking with over 1 million
students from around the world through
his experience at deloitte and growing
up as an immigrant june founded hello to
fulfill his dream of empowering others
to expand their lives through language
please welcome june
hi kevin nice to meet you it's a
pleasure
you too
i've seen you roasting a lot of people
i'm a little nervous but i'll do my best
don't worry about it it's just the
biggest moment of your life absolutely
awesome
great
well
welcome mr wonderful to hello we are on
on-demand language learning platform for
speaking
in real time you can click a button and
start practicing with a native speaker
via video chat
in simple words we help language
learners become fluent
as an immigrant i understand the
challenges of learning a new language
the biggest one being finding
opportunities to speak
language learners spend most of their
time in their textbooks and not speaking
but grammar and vocab are not the best
way to learn and you never become fluent
by just reading and listening
on our platform you can not only talk
with a native speaker in three seconds
but also practice with other students 24
7 for free
the best way to learn a new language is
by practicing speaking with native
speakers and immersing yourself in the
culture 24 7 and hollow provides that
interaction you need for you to be
fluent and speak like a native speaker
we launched our product a couple years
ago currently we have over a million
students with hundreds of thousands of
monthly active students using our
product and the best part is we're
growing all organically and our users
are spending more than 30 minutes per
day on average practicing and speaking
on hollow
over the past eight months our monthly
revenue has tripled and we're projected
to double our revenue in the next four
months
our business model is really simple if
you want to practice with other students
it's all free
but if you want to
you know become fluent faster you can
use our paid services the first one is
student to student you pay ten dollars
per month and unlock some of our premium
features just like spotify and youtube
second one is marketplace between
students and teachers if you want to
practice with native speakers and learn
with teachers in a more structured way
you can pay for our classes and we just
take a commission fee like uber and
airbnb
the online language learning market is
huge and growing by 22 billion dollars
over the next four years
education is moving online quickly and
the online language learning market is
projected to be 42 billion dollars
growing by 20 year-over-year
so so far kevin we've only focused on
the english funding market but for us to
capture this huge opportunity we're
introducing 10 new languages this year
so our vision and mission is to help all
language learners become fluent and
dream big
and mr wonderful i mean if i didn't know
how to speak english i would not be here
presenting and talking with you right
now so what we're working on is
improving the lives of many and this is
just the beginning of hollow
thank you
great presentation questions number one
do you know your customer acquisition
costs in terms of the ones that are
paying you the 9.99 and do they is the
lifetime value more than the acquisition
cost
yes so the lifetime value of our paying
customers is about thirty dollars
already and in terms of our cac since
we're growing organically honestly we
don't have a lot of data but we've
actually tested two with two countries
first one is korea so when we tested
with korea our cac was about 59 49 cents
per customer
and also in india it was about three
cents so we're starting with those two
main countries and then we're excited to
test and experiment with other countries
as well now when you provide the
platform for teachers they have their
own fees i assume depending on their own
success
can i buy a you know more successful
teacher than a lower successful one how
do i get pricing on that and how do you
have any sense of controlling it or you
just do an open marketplace and take an
18 to 30 percent commission
yeah so we have a minimum price that our
teachers need to abide by but above that
they can choose any prices they want so
the cool thing about our product is that
we allow our teachers to be able to
build a following and also make money at
the same time so by focusing on group
learning they're able to teach hundreds
of students at the same time and once
they find paying customers they can
teach you know smaller groups or
one-on-one classes so you know above 15
per hour they can choose their own
prices
and do you allow the students to rate
them
absolutely so right after their lessons
they always give a review to teachers so
if they're not good at teaching they
won't be able to find good students okay
if
by word of mouth i get a hundred people
to come to the site
what percentage of them become 999
paying customers so about one percent of
our monthly active students are paying
customers so we have a few thousand
paying customers right now out of 215
000 monthly active students how many
followers do you have on social media on
social media we have about a million on
facebook we have a couple hundred
thousand i think about a hundred
thousand
uh followers on tick tock
can you give me some sense of attrition
in other words if i want to learn
english and i mean
you know born in india and i'm slowly
getting better at it because they teach
english and school there as well
how long do i stay on the platform
before i say well i've learned my
language i want to move on
in terms of paying customers they
usually pay for about six months but if
you look at the long period of our
like all freemium users as well some of
our users are using our product for
years so language learning actually
takes a long time it's just not gonna be
for three months five months that's
actually a lie if language learning
platforms actually say that for me like
i've learned english for decades like
two 20 years plus um so for our students
as well they understand what it takes to
be fluent and speak like a native
speaker so if you want to start learning
a new language you can go to platforms
like duolingo that's a great platform to
start learning a new language for basics
but if you want to be fluent and speak
like a native speaker to communicate you
can come to hollow and always find
opportunities to speak through our
platform
how much question well it's the most
important one how much cash you burning
a month
our net burn rate is about fifty
thousand dollars per month so how much
do you how much do you have in the bank
right now so we have about 450 000 in
cash got it okay very very interesting
very good presentation you knew your
numbers that's very important thank you
thank you kevin
great job thank you june okay next up we
have geocloud technologies abiodun
please unmute your mic and turn on your
camera
abiodun is the co-founder and ceo of
geocloud technologies under his
leadership they were made part of google
for startups geocloud technologies has
the ability to stack aggregate and
optimize geographically relevant data
from multiple sources into a single
location-based index please welcome
abiodun
thank you for that intro good afternoon
everybody good afternoon
mr wonderful
um
i'll go ahead and start uh we are geo
cloud we are near me search platform
that basically creates customized
location-based experiences for consumers
businesses and government organizations
so to start we're creating a
personalized map and communication tool
that helps you find your home wherever
you are in the world
meet michael he's a 27 year old software
developer that just moved from tulsa
oklahoma to new york city to take a new
job at google however he has no friends
or family in this new location
so for the next 12 months he's going to
spend 30 of his free available time
searching for those people places and
things that make him feel at home
he's going to go to google to find local
businesses and eateries he's going to go
to tinder to find local friends
he's also going to go to eventbrite and
meet up to find local events and groups
that share similar interests with him as
you see this process is very cumbersome
as he has to jump from app to app
without really being fulfilled with the
one thing that he's yearning for the
ability to connect with his community
and feel at home
so we created our first product ugo to
help people like michael find events
find places find groups
and also find everything that he's
looking for locally
so with eugeo when you find your you can
find local events
uh basically here in la there's a walk
what kind of music festival happening
locally he can get a ride maybe take an
uber or lyft
it's happening in the next couple of
days we also have a local newspaper
where we show you you know whether local
news is happening locally
you can add content to the map and
choose how long you want it to exist you
can also customize the type of content
you're dropping uh it can be event maybe
it's the climate justif activism event
tourism and different things like that
and share locally
yes um so the technology we're creating
is we're building this repository of
aggregated and optimized data right so
we're aggregating government data
business information user generated
content weather data local news and
placing on the map and creating uh
solutions out of that as i mentioned ugo
app is the first one we're also creating
other mobile experiences interactive
websites on an api and sdk to allow
others to basically enrich their own
technology with our platform
so we've gone up to a good start within
the past year we've aggregated over 11
000 app users who basically love the app
in terms of uh the ability to aggregate
information showing what's what's
happening locally and ultimately just
the ability to connect
we have a strong team of
business
business developers as well business
people as well as developers to grow and
scale this we're ivy league trained
we've worked with some of the bigger
companies in the world that leverage
location data already to enrag and
enhance people's lives and have over 24
years of combined experience we're
currently raising a pre-seed round uh we
have michael donahue one of the founding
team members from whatsapp who's our
notable investor we're leveraging the
money to further build out the product
amplify our voice and also grow our team
thank you for your time
thank you what's your business model how
are you planning on making money with
this
yes so we have a couple ways we're
looking to monetize uh the first is
through advertising uh letting local
businesses uh advertise on the platform
whether it's you know promoted pin uh
being the top of search results um
that's the first way we're monetizing in
the app um and then outside of that as
you grow our platform we're gonna offer
uh
access to analytics uh also our api and
sdk
now let's talk about the analytics if
i'm if i download the app do i have to
pre-seed it with a tremendous amount of
personal information about my likes and
dislikes regarding the content i want to
be shown or the or the social or the
music or the event
how does it know what i like
yes so um when you first log into the
apple ads ask for a few interest um and
then over time we'll start learning more
about you right so we're learning you
know your different likes and the
different things that you're into to
eventually customize this um and it
basically would be a customized uh map
based on your interest so we have a
recommendation as well built-in so we're
using machine learning and ai to do that
as well
so
am i
are you abiding by the personal
information metrics that have been
imposed on you by apple because how are
you getting that data i'm trying to
figure out
if facebook can't do it how can you do
it and that's one of the biggest
challenges in the market today how do
you how how do you become relevant to me
in terms of my likes and dislikes so
that i don't waste my time having to
tell you what i want you just know it
yeah so the way we're collecting
interest is you uh in telling us right
you tell us you know hey i'm interested
in events tourism um we're also learning
about the things that you do like on our
platform and we're using all this data
to really customize it to you so it's
more about you giving us you know we
want to customize and tell this to you
so the more information you give us the
more useful
our platform is to you
you only have 11 000 active users right
now so it's going to be very hard to
sell advertising how big in scale do you
think you have to be before you can sell
ads on this to start getting some
revenue
yes i think um in terms of density in
different cities we're looking at
hitting a target of 10 000 users to be
able to open it up to small to
medium-sized businesses to be able to
drive traction um and drive users to
their local businesses
is there any geographic distribution in
terms of uses right now is it all in one
city or is it in multiple locations
yes so um it's right now it's
distributed uh globally um so we have
you know most of our traction is coming
from west africa um and also we are so
now we're focusing on a few key cities
so really grow density um so this app is
available to anybody to download we have
over 20 000 cities on the map where
basically we we gather information but
now we're focused on a few key cities uh
to grow density and then rinse and
repeat it and spread it out to other
cities um so we've seen a lot of
traction in west africa specifically
legos we're focused on the new york and
also atlanta georgia
last question
do you have any idea what your customer
acquisition cost is yet
yes we're seeing an average of 50 cents
um through our digital uh ads campaign
that we've run and also we're getting a
lot of organic uh downloads through app
store optimization so we've done a lot
of with our keywords uh we've seen a
huge boost in terms of we're going from
um we have we have landing pages that's
right people were averaging like four
downloads per day now we're at 10. we're
going to continue to optimize that uh to
grow more users and also going to
leverage ambassadors um to also get
users on the platform as well
okay great thank you very much
thank you
great thank you there we go done okay
next up we have enrichly margot please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
margo jordan is an award-winning serial
social entrepreneur she is the founder
of enrichly a self-esteem based
e-learning platform and gaming app that
helps children reach their full
potential please welcome margot
hi
i'm going to share my screen
and get ready
to
okay hi mr wonderful so happy to be here
um
issues like
self-neglect violent behavior and
suicide have one thing in common amongst
youth and that's unhealthy self-esteem
what if i told you that there are over a
hundred million children around the
world that suffer from low self-esteem
well my name is margo jordan and my team
and i are pioneering a new industry that
we call pdtech personal development
technology and we're making self-esteem
development accessible to kids around
the globe
we already have 11 licensees in two
countries over 2 500 individual
enrollments and we've secured 85 plus
school contracts
so 75 of kids ages 7 through 11 suffer
from low self-esteem there has literally
been a 57
increase in suicide death due to low
self-esteem in children
so when a child has low self-esteem it's
a problem for parents because they're
dealing with the child who makes bad
decisions they might be socially awkward
they're being bullied and they have
unhealthy coping skills schools on the
other hand they're faced with health and
wellness declines increase in student
violence overall performance is low and
a decrease in academic achievement
this is why we created this self-esteem
based digital health e-learning platform
and gaming app we're using machine
learning gamification and an on-site
mental health curriculum to make
self-esteem improvement fun for k-12
so
here's how it works a trusted adult will
enroll the child into the platform the
platform is collecting actionable data
via our pre-core surveys we're allowing
the children to continue through the
course the system is learning from the
user via machine learning and develop
algorithms we then deliver data to key
decision makers and make suggestions
like course continuation therapy or even
counseling our interactive self-esteem
courses are implemented in schools via 6
10 or 13 week sessions and then parents
have the option to subscribe they get
unlimited access to the courses content
and the curriculum that we provide
our competitive landscape is really
strong because there are no other
platforms on the market strategically
targeting self-esteem development in a
peer-driven fashion this allows us to
confidently say we'll capture 10 percent
of the sum leading to acquisition or ipo
so our revenue model is pretty
straightforward we're generating sales
through licensees parent subscriptions
and school contracts giving us an 80
plus profit margin
our customer acquisition strategy is
pretty straightforward we're going to
attend trade shows and exhibits we're
going to use the power of social media
with mom influencers we're going to put
funding towards digital ads and use rfps
and buying cooperatives to continue to
get school contracts
this all underwrites our capabilities to
gross 104 million by 2024.
and looking at some exit strategies
we've been looking at possible acquirers
we're actually in active conversations
with paper to possibly acquire us in
about 12 to 24 months
so with my background in finance with a
passion for social impact as a military
veteran i've been molded into the
perfect leader for this company and i've
put together a team with a combined 50
years of relevant experience they will
ensure that the technology is both
effective and impactful in global
markets
so back our platform and help us tackle
this issue of unhealthy self-esteem and
kids globally
thank you
margo you mentioned three sources of
revenue can you give me more granularity
on that please
yes so we generate sales through
licensees so maybe an organization will
license out the platform and they will
deliver the on-site curriculum for
example rise recovery they offer
substance abuse
recovery for teens and adolescents so
they're using our platform and on-site
curriculum to help decrease the amount
of drug use amongst teens parents will
subscribe to the platform they're paying
9.99 a month and we're actually getting
those parents right now from our school
contracts so schools serve as our
revenue generating lead generator we get
access to the schools and the parents
they trust our platform and they trust
what we're delivering and then we're
converting anywhere from five to six
percent of those students into monthly
paying customers so we'll get a school
contract for anywhere from 7 500 to our
most recent
180 000 contract with the largest school
district in houston
the school contracts are they annual
yes the school contracts are annual
right now we're on the longest contract
with every school we've been awarded
contracts with which are five-year
contracts has any school tried you and
then dropped you
no we always schools always renew with
us so before the pandemic we had
contracts with schools schools were
closed so we had to shift to do the
digital platform all of the schools
brought us back in and now that we have
the digital offering it just makes our
platform that much better and if i'm a
parent can i see the content that you
mentioned unlimited access to the
content if i'm not paying the 9.99 you
can see some of the free content for
example we do live webinars so we'll
bring in tween celebrities and
influencers on the platform those are
completely free for the kids to join in
for example we brought in disney's
ravens home so we brought in those kids
that webinar lives on our platform and
it's totally free and you know they were
on there talking about social media and
self-esteem and so what do i get for the
9.99 what's proprietary about what i'm
getting there so you get access to the
courses so when we deliver the
information to the schools it's just one
course delivered through our enrichment
coordinator and it usually lasts about
six to ten weeks and then that's the end
of that program but when you pay 9.99
you get access to all of the courses the
continuing learning the live webinars
the community that we offer the free
resources and then also the connection
to the therapists and the counselors we
service like a liaison for parents can i
see if my child's improving as they're
going through the course if i'm paying
the 9.99 are there any measurable
metrics i can look at
yes so we actually use a self-esteem
survey from the cdc it's a 10 basic
questionnaire that measures if the
student has low medium or healthy
self-esteem we actively give those
reports to the parents through our data
automation and that's what we call our
actionable data so we see a
statistically significant improvement in
across all boards so all the cohorts any
child that goes through our platform
they're always improving their
self-esteem um and parents like it
because self-esteem is like a muscle you
can't just work on it one day and then
think that everything is all better this
is something that has to be constantly
worked on which is why we deliver that
data to the parents
i'm i'm intrigued about your revenue uh
split what percentage of your revenue
and let's see if you can give me a
number for what you think you'll do in
this calendar year 2022 is going to come
directly from schools
um probably about 75 80 will come
directly from schools and that's mainly
because schools are where we're
generating a ton of revenue from right
now in the long run we will see that
parent subscription piece rev up as we
gamify the platform more as we offer
more courses get more webinars on the
platform so that will more than likely
be a split and we'll see 40 from
parent subscriptions 40 from the school
contracts and then the rest from the
licensing of the platform and what do
you think revenue will be in 2022 all in
um we're look right now we actually have
about 1.2 million in the pipeline um so
we will more than likely close out this
year anywhere from 1.2 to 1.7
last question and how long does it take
you between when you first contact the
school to when you close a contract with
them how long is that closing cycle so
our sales cycle is super short and we
actually have a 95 close rate with
school so it's anywhere from three to
six weeks that we contact the school
they say yes to the program and then we
have a contract and purchase order out
um and honestly a lot of the schools pay
us beforehand usually with schools it's
like a 30-day net but they're paying out
those contracts before we even get the
work started
thank you very good presentation thank
you
great job thank you margo thank you okay
i just want to do a quick reset for
anyone who is just joining us this is
start engines pitch show with mr
wonderful
and i'm seeing a lot of comments of
people who are either asking how can i
apply or i did apply we got thousands of
applicants and this is the case for
every single one of these shows and
we're really only able to choose five
companies but if you are watching this
and you're interested in pitching at the
next competition or if you just want to
learn more about raising capital on
start engine go to start engine.com
shark we will have our team members
reach out to you we can ask you more
about your business and what your goals
are
uh and also i wanted to do another thank
you to our partners we have some amazing
partners that we've been working with uh
across the last few months plug and play
deal brex forecaster and benzinga that
actually did a live show this morning
that was really fun to watch uh and
kevin so we've had three pitches so far
we have two left what are what are you
thinking how does this compare to past
shows you know really um and i said this
every pitch competition they just keep
getting better now either you're getting
better at curating them or there's just
a whole lot more that's coming forward
now as people realize that equity
crowdfunding is a better place to go in
times of extreme volatility
in financial services which is what's
happening out there the market's been
wild so i think this is sort of the
renaissance period for equity
crowdfunding and it's being reflected in
the quality of these deals any one of
these three so far
has a great opportunity and i think
we'll find investors
yeah i totally agree and really we have
seen amazing uh increases in our numbers
for applicants we used to have you know
a few hundred now we're getting
thousands of applicants coming in every
single week that want to raise money on
start engine so the quality is really
going up the interest is going up and i
think this is moving away from being
sort of an alternative way of getting
capital to becoming much more mainstream
and i've got to tell you already i'm
miserable about having to make a choice
i mean this is brutal that that's our
job we want to make it as hard as
possible for you kevin that's great
let's hear the next one okay so next up
we have applied bioplastics alex please
unmute your mic and turn on your camera
alex blum is the co-founder and chief
impact officer of applied bioplastics he
co-founded applied bioplastics to
address the carbon footprint of durable
plastics please welcome alex
hey mr wonderful how are you today very
good
wonderful so i'm alex i co-founded
applied bioplastics with colin ardern
and in applied bioplastics we are
decarbonizing the plastic industry and
changing the future of polymers
so plastic is essential to modern
society and despite many efforts to
reduce reuse and recycle humans are
actually using more plastic than ever
before
now besides the obvious trash problem a
major downside of this is that plastic
currently accounts for about seven
percent of annual carbon emissions and
this is expected to grow to 20 percent
by 2050. there are efforts to temper
this demand through reuse and recycling
of course as well as plant-based
alternatives unfortunately these are
limited primarily to packaging leaving
about two-thirds of the market virtually
untouched so how do we improve the
sustainability of durable plastic items
that these efforts don't address like
containers furniture appliance housings
building materials and transportation
components well at applied bioplastics
we have commercialized a platform
technology that allows us to produce
durable bio composites from just about
any type of plant matter
with about any type of plastic so that
includes virgin plastics recycled
plastics and bio plastics those plastics
that we create are mechanically
identical to the plastic they're
replacing which enables their use in
standard manufacturing processes meaning
there's no cost to adopt we've been
through several internal and external
plastic molding trials and we know with
certainty that our plastics uh work in
about eighty percent of all plastic
applications for polypropylene we're
going to be doing polyethylene next year
so our durable polymers incorporate
sustainable plant fibers available all
over the world which reduces their net
carbon emissions compared to the
incumbents because both the plant fiber
and our proprietary processing
technology are inexpensive we can win
now against the big petrochemical
players on price today while also
slashing those carbon emissions for
hundreds of thousands of products
our solution is easy to adopt for both
companies that produce and companies
that use plastics because we built our
technology around the existing
production infrastructure so there's no
cost to adopt um applied bioplastics is
the hottest brand in composites which
helps us hire we've won every industry
award we've entered in the last two
years and the last time i put out a job
wreck mr wonderful i got 1400
applications in the first 48 hours
we built a sales pipeline for our
thermoplastic products that contains
nearly 40 global brands with multiple
paid pilots underway with some of the
largest manufacturers in the world
including nascent partnerships with
several petrochemical suppliers we have
advanced 90 million dollars of our 400
million dollar pipeline into the paid
pilot phase already um in the last 10
months it should be obvious why we're
seeing so much traction after only three
years of work we have a solution that
meets every need of the current market
while solving an issue that is top of
mind for nearly every major manufacturer
we've taken away the cost of adoption
the barriers to scale the limited
feedstocks required by specialty
plastics producers and the cost
difference between alternatives and
incumbents at a time when most
manufacturers are making public
commitments to reduce their
environmental footprint mr wonderful we
have a tiger by the tail you know that's
dangerous but we need your help to put
it in a headlock we're currently raising
in order to get signed commitments from
several of our prospects we have 38
immediately seizable opportunities that
span in industry and manufacturing this
is of course a complex handshake type of
sale and while we recently poached an
amazing head of sales from a major
petrochemical player we need to hire the
rest of her department better yet if
anyone watching joins us you won't be
alone we have soft commits for a
significant part of our round already
and are gaining momentum both in sales
and fundraise we're changing the future
of plastics and i want everyone watching
to reach out if you're interested in
purchasing licensing our technology
being part of our team or investing join
us and see just how sustainable durable
plastics can be
alex what's your business model you
selling or licensing the technology or
actually selling plastic sheets how are
you making money so it's a bit all of
the above so it's not sheets it's uh if
you look at the camera here it is
pelletized plastic feedstock so it goes
right in your injection mold you stick
it right in the hopper um so today what
we're doing in order to gain market
traction is is selling directly right
we've got our partners who are helping
us create our plastic we're selling that
plastic directly to manufacturers um i'd
love to be able to name them i can't i'm
under nda with everybody but um
unfortunately anyways um you know so to
gain that market traction to prove that
we can do what we we say we can do we're
making the plastic and we're selling it
directly um we have just recently
started a couple partnerships with some
major petrochemical players with those
what we're doing is we're providing them
with the treated fiber feedstock as a
co-feed stock for the plastic that they
already produce so in order to combine
those two things we have to license our
technology to them so they're paying us
a licensing fee and they're also
purchasing uh the treated fiber so it's
a dual revenue stream in the case of
licensing are you constrained in terms
of manufacturing those pellets how much
can you make if you start to scale so
the wonderful thing is that our stuff
uses standard manufacturing machines so
the twin screw extruder is the is the
machine that is used to compound plastic
all over the world there are thousands
and thousands of them um
because our stuff is compatible we don't
need to go buy those i'm not going to
ask you to purchase me a three-quarters
of a million dollar extruder because i
can just make a partnership and have
somebody make that so what we're we're
limited as far as scale is where do we
find the the fiber how do we set up the
the uh the fiber treatment facilities
that sort of thing um we've addressed
that with a distributed model we're
taking very low capex uh off the shelf
machinery like a grinder a dual reaction
chamber and an oven super standard stuff
we can set that up just about anywhere
in the world treat that fiber get it
into a shippable format because you
don't want to be shipping low bulk
density plant fiber all over the world
that's a loser that's a loser on dollars
that's a loser on carbon so what we do
is we grind it down so it's really dense
and then we ship it over to the
compounder the compounder compounds it
into the plastic sends it to the brand
manufacturer for injection molding
um in your story of reducing carbon is
any of it involve purchasing carbon
credits are you doing anything like that
or you're just reducing emissions
because the plastic is more stable
doesn't break down when it does it's
more bio-intense
that is all correct there and we
absolutely do not uh intend to to do our
business on carbon credits we can in the
future maybe sell carbon credits as part
of our package but our unit economics
are amazing
we have a gigantic margin on a commodity
um and we also have a gigantic co2
margin we don't need to sell carbon
credits in order to be impactful uh both
financially and on the environment
who is your competition
our competition is the plastics market
right so you've got um you've got your
specialty petrochemical makers you have
your standard petrochemical makers you
have your uh specialty alternative
plastics makers the folks who are making
bioplastics now the difference between
them and us that last group is that most
of them do what's called a total
conversion of cellulose they break down
the biomass they turn it into a gas they
condense it into a liquid and then it
becomes a resin right
that's really expensive and energy
intensive what we've done is we've
shortcutted that process and made plant
fibers themselves compatible with other
plastics so here's the deal we don't
compete with them we're their part so
for the the alternative plastics makers
that are trying to get in the market
with these really awesome total
conversion of biomass plastics that are
way too expensive usually two to three
hundred percent of the cost of virgin
plastics we can help them bring that
cost down because our stuff's like five
hundred dollars a metric ton their stuff
is five thousand dollars a metric ton
slash out forty percent of theirs put in
hours all of a sudden you've got
something that that's a lot more
palatable to the market when we're also
talking about alternatives like recycled
plastics we can bring the price down on
that we can bring the co2 down on that
and then of course virgin plastics same
thing reduce the price reduce the co2 so
we see the market as as all potential
partners not necessarily competitors
last question
what do you think your sales will be in
2022
so we are projecting for this year about
30 million dollars in uh commitments um
i wouldn't say sales what we're looking
for is capacity reservation agreements
what i'm doing with this round is i'm i
am extending my runway getting it to the
point where i can get multiple capacity
reservation agreements from multiple
large manufacturers and then going to
raise a series a on the strength of
those capacity reservation agreements
start bringing in that revenue sometime
in 2023.
okay and do you own all your ip i know
it's supposed to be the last question
but does applied bio own this or did you
license this technology from somebody
else we purchased the technology
basically we purchased um a core piece
of the technology um we also hired the
inventor of that technology so he works
for us now
and then we created our own ip and
actually today we are converting our
provisional patent applications into
true patent applications um so that
should be maybe about a year before we
get those patents awarded we're going to
be able to do business with that
immediately
got it thank you very much
thank you mr wonderful
okay thank you so much alex
we now have our final pitch of the day
blurp
derek please unmute your mic and turn on
your camera
derek amore is the co-founder and ceo of
blurp blurp is the soundbite sharing
platform of live streams and voice chats
making it easy to search and share sound
memes please welcome derek hey thank you
so much and kevin excited to share blurb
with you today
so as we know the largest
uh social media platform today is tick
tock and it's growing so fast as users
are able to add music and sound bites to
their video content now there's been
millions of dollars put towards music
licensing and music search but no one's
been able to solve sound bite search
blurp makes that easy with over one
million plus index sound bytes that are
integrated into the platforms users love
today a lot of people like to compare us
to the giphy of sound i'd like to show
you how we're actually 45 times bigger
than gifs on live streams and how it's
been able to enhance a moment in a way
that gifs are not able to
we've collabed with voice actors and
creators with blurb users are able to
find the perfect sound and make moments
like
these the guy that's literally always on
my 40 page and i'm like bro can you
imagine if that happened to me
blurb is the best place to search create
and share sound mutes
this is how
so we've been able to go to over 35 000
daily active users as we focus as
content creators on live stream
platforms like twitch
we get to uh 760 000 blurp shared weekly
growing at 25 month over month we've
done this all organically through our
tick tock with over 800 000 followers
we're actually almost at 900 000 just
this morning by promoting our products
showcasing how blurbs can be used on
live streams and showcasing the content
creators that are using our platform
all right we have three primary revenue
models today one is our pay to share
model where viewers are able to access
our database of sound bytes that have
blur integrated on their stream and pay
to share live on stream we take a 20
commission the second is our streamer
subscription which unlocks a subset of
premium features for those streamers and
lastly is our sound pack marketplace
where we've partnered with content
creators
for and voice actors to be able to
monetize their sonic branding
since uh raising funding last year we've
been able to double our revenue and be
able to get to about three hundred
thousand dollars in arr uh our
subscription model is actually growing
18 week over week since launching just a
couple of months ago
the big opportunity is we monetize
streamers and viewers by adding more
subscription features for both of them
and allowing them to be able to share
blurps in all the places that they love
later this fall we'll go ahead and
launch our subscription model for our
viewers and then launch into new markets
like facebook gaming and youtube we
already have the technology there it's
just a matter of marketing and being
able to make it a positive user
experience once we've established this
as a culture that sound sharing is
something that every content creator
needs to have to monetize their viewers
more social platforms will be looking to
do this and we'll take this into the
metaverse
i have two co-founders aaron who started
this just four years ago
and evan who handles design and branding
we raised our precede just last year of
a million dollars with funds like the
alexa
alexa fund and convoy ventures using
gaming
today we're raising a 1.5 million dollar
round on a safe to get to three hundred
thousand content creators and fifty
million dollars in ar excited to answer
your questions kevin
yeah so this is all about acquiring
customers and if i looked at your 35 000
daily where would i find 80 of them on
tick tock uh so about 85 percent of them
would be on twitch and discord
okay so do you know what it's costing
you to acquire these customers yet so
today we've done no paid marketing all
of this has come organically as we've
created content and shared actually
videos of our content creators on tick
tock
you have nowhere in here an advertising
model why
um we do recognize that this is an
opportunity for us to monetize giphy is
ultimately uh they've only monetized
through advertising um but what's unique
about sound is that you've been able to
purchase uh sound but you've never you
know you've never purchased a gif and so
we're more focused on monetizing these
models initially
and we think that ultimately it'll be
much more valuable platform in the long
run as gif was purchased by facebook and
tenor was purchased by um
google at you know 400 million dollars
plus without essentially any
monetization other than ads and
sponsored posts uh so that's why we're
kind of holding off on that to look at
mass scale but we think that's probably
the last monetization method that we'll
employ
do you pay royalties to the actual
owners of the sound bytes
so we have two parts of our library we
have a dmca free library where our users
are actually once creating the content
so taking youtube clips twitch clips etc
and these are all being used for free
but we do have a premium set of our
library that is licensed and working
with content creators and
you know music
industries as well what does that look
like what percentage of revenue do you
have to pay out on royalties on when it
is proprietary sound
so right now we're only doing a one-time
purchase uh that will unlock the content
similar to like a sticker pack online or
whatsapp and that's a 70 30 split
between the creator and us
who gets to 70
other crater
okay
and what percentage do you think if this
scales is going to be that kind of
business
uh i'm sorry what what percentage i'm
trying to figure out if you're really an
agency are you are you sort of a cameo
where you're basically aggregating
content taking a an agent's fee
of other because i'm wondering over time
if this scales
which sounds are going to be the most
interesting for people to actually use
are they going to be celebrity sounds
are they going to be famous quotes what
will it be
i mean i think as we look towards the
the future there's obviously a lot of
learnings that we can take from nfts but
what we're really looking at is the this
the ability for you to be able to
support a creator and so by creating
some limitations to the number of people
that can purchase a sound pack that's
where we think that that rarity is going
to really uh expand and so as we work
with content creators our real big goal
is to help small content creators uh
monetize their their platform and their
unique brand as well as large creators
um and so what we're finding is viral
growth through communities as one
streamer picks up blurb they make sound
content that their viewers love they
purchase it for anywhere from five to
ten dollars and then they can share it
in their text messages share it on
discord wherever it might be and so we
see that perpetuating out from small
communities outward but from a go to
market strategy the next big opportunity
for us is to actually pay to work with
some of these larger influencers where
all of the small and medium-sized
creators um are actually watching them
and would like to use blurp on their
platform
so the plan is at some point to start
dropping proprietary and unique burps
and just see what the market's going to
do in terms of bidding for them is that
it
um so we're actually already doing this
we've worked with large voice actors on
like avatar last airbender five nights
at freddy's and started selling those
sound packs we've already sold over a
thousand sound packs since launching
just some months ago
interesting very interesting well thank
you very much derek absolutely thank you
so
much okay thank you derek that was our
final pitch so those were uh some pretty
great pitches a huge thank you to all
five companies that participated it is
not easy to pitch mr wonderful it
definitely seems like from uh your
advice at the beginning of this kevin
you said know your numbers i felt like
most of them really did know their
numbers yeah i think they're getting it
i think they've probably seen some of
the other pitches in the past
and obviously learning from mistakes
made prior but the pictures are getting
better and better each time so they
understand what it takes to win
but these deals are
what's interesting is they are they are
so relevant to today's market these are
these are all new ideas in terms of
using digital using direct to consumer
using social media to grow a business i
mean there's not a whole lot of retail
strategy in this which is the new
generation of businesses in fact i don't
invest in retail strategies anymore i'm
looking for ways to develop communities
and having direct relationships with my
customers and almost all of these deals
do that so they they've obviously come
through the pandemic with the new
digital 2.0 america at the forefront of
their thoughts of growth
yeah it is really interesting to see how
much these companies shift over time
just the types of companies what their
strategy is so before i run through all
of your deliberation everyone who's
watching on zoom should see a poll pop
up on their screen this is going to be
your chance to vote for your favorite of
today's pitches again kevin is going to
be choosing the first prize winner and
then all of you watching will choose the
crowd favorite who will receive five
thousand dollars okay kevin so run me
through what you're thinking for each of
these companies
um hello is really interesting because
it's a proven market and they're
basically monetizing the relationship
between a teacher and a student in
language it's extremely motivating for
people particularly that are moving into
different economies that want to expand
uh their potential for their own careers
so i find that very attractive and it's
a new way there's so many of these
platforms out already but this was
interesting because basically you can go
in tiptoe your way in for a few months
at 9.99 and then get serious with a with
an accredited teacher or do both so i
feel that their customer acquisition
costs are going to remain low under a
dollar and they're monetizing out at 30
dollars so there's a really interesting
model of poor gasoline on the fire there
very good geocloud is not as proven yet
but the idea is interesting and the
question for me is
how fast can they make it easier and
easier for a new person to basically
download the app and be seamless in
terms of getting relatively curated
ideas whether it be meeting other people
going to you know restaurants that
they're used to the kinds of foods that
makes sense but it's how fast i can do
that because the model is very early
margot's idea for k to 12
that's genius i mean my goodness
i used to sell to the 110 000 school
buildings in the learning company this
was a problem
every decade it remains a problem so
she's got a solution
and it sounds like she does that's also
very a very scalable business uh applied
bio i mean that that's so on trend for
you know i i wouldn't bless since we had
our last pitch competition the sec put
out
a memorandum saying that they are
considering auditing carbon credits and
the companies that are public that have
their financial statements audited
better be prepared to sign off that they
are actually carbon neutral when they
say they are and that's going to be a
really interesting issue for large
corporate companies that this that
applied bio is going to be servicing and
you know derek slurp very cool i mean no
one's done that before and i think it's
it's not that proprietary but they're
first movers so i can see merit on all
these deals um
right before before you announce your
your winner i just want to remind
everyone what is at stake here so the
winner is going to be receiving 25 000
cash prize from mr wonderful a
one-on-one with start engine ceo and the
co-founder of activision games howard
marks and amazing services and prizes
from our partners at plug and play brex
deal forecaster and benzinga
okay kevin are you ready to announce
yeah and i i uh like i gotta tell you i
really struggled as always but this time
it's just brutal the the three that i
uh you had to pick you know that they're
i think any one of them could be number
one is applied bio uh hello
and uh what margot is doing um you know
in richly i mean that that is such a
great idea but
the i i had to go with applied bio
because the market that they're
addressing is so
huge and it's global and it's a huge
problem and everybody knows about it and
people have all kinds of feelings about
plastic so it's top of mind it was a
fantastic presentation
alex wins um but you know
it was i mean you're making my life so
hard joanna i mean it's crazy we aim to
do that yeah we want to have the best
companies possible pitching well you all
of these have merit they all do um
applied bio is just the presentation was
close to perfect um
nailed it on the numbers nailed it on
you know the questions about the ip
i i couldn't find a flaw in what he was
saying and i'm well aware of this
addressable size of this market
so um
congrats alex amazing alex if you want
to unmute yourself and just turn your
camera on for a quick word
thank you so much uh i am i'm honored um
you know really tough competition here
everybody's got you know an amazing app
an amazing idea an amazing company um
you know we we are on the cusp of a
revolution in plastics and um we're
really honored that you've chosen to
join us uh mr wonderful and and uh to
everybody here uh thank you so much for
for having us and for the opportunity
thank you so much alex okay and so as i
mentioned before start engine is all
about the crowd we obviously care what
mr wonderful thinks but we also care
about what all of you think so the crowd
favorite was hello so congratulations
i've seen throughout this entire event a
ton of comments super fans in here
obviously people agreed with kevin uh
that they're one of the contenders but
hello congratulations you got the 5 000
cash prize from the crowd you know
joanna this is the first time i'm not
pissed off at the crowd for not going
with me because i mean this is great
i was that was such a great deal too i
mean and global global i mean obviously
english but french spanish coming next
all of this korean it's brilliant it's
brilliant
yeah i i totally agree and the one
amazing thing that i want to know i know
people are still getting to know what
start engine is in this chat this is
really you know here we're just choosing
between five companies but when you
apply to raise on start engine we have
you know 50 plus companies launching
every single month to our community of
investors so you have the chance to
recreate this with our massive community
of over 800 000 people that are
interested in these deals so i wanted to
give a huge thank you to all five
companies that pitch to get today and a
huge thank you of course to all of our
sponsors and kevin to you another great
pitch competition in the books
thank you we'll see you again next
quarter and it's just going to keep
getting bigger and better
of course and for anyone who wants to
pitch at the next show go to start
engine.com shark
we are going to start reviewing those
applications i think as early as next
week we never we never rest on this
kevin
thank you
okay thanks everyone